this is Startalk now this one is really
for Neil uh Mary uh and I'm reading it
Neil because I'm not sure what this
guy's talking about okay and this is
from Nick sahs from ski says from ski
you think that's right says Fran ski
right
suds suds front the front ski says Ron
if you start punching names correctly
then we won't know to do with you
Madison however you want and that's your
thing now that's my thing I don't use
the France key I don't know Sebastian
right so what else here we go um this
way says I'm a young sci-fi writer and
fantasy I'm currently working on a hard
science fiction book my question is how
much do we understand here's the thing
meal exotic particles what if any effect
they do have on the human body and and
then he says if you could put a blurb
about my book I really appreciate yeah
so I don't think I'm gonna do the blurb
about the book but well I think I have a
way to link this back to Mary but we we
have the portfolio of particles that
exist that it measured that names their
masses they have you know energies in
different states and this sort of thing
and half-lives and so some particles
just go straight through you like
neutrinos right billions go through you
every square centimeter every second
from the Sun and they do nothing to us
they don't interact what matters is if
they interact with you that's the
difference okay and if they interact
they could do damage and so so this is a
so if you want to weaponize a particle
you would make some kind of device that
you know contains particles that will
interact with your body in some way yes
with your DNA that's with your skin mess
with whatever and then that becomes a
weaponized Raygun basically so you make
the particles a delivery system for some
type of debilitation correct correct now
we do this for for electromagnetic
energy so there's a there's a movable
microwave device which is an it's a
non-lethal
anti-personnel weapon that is non-lethal
so if there's a crowd of people you
drive up this truck you aim this antenna
at the people and it's like you just put
them all in a microwave oven now do you
first get them to hold a burrito oh we
can eat it on the way you've got to take
the wrapper off exactly so so what
happens is their skin starts feeling hot
and they and they want to go out of the
beam so they scatter it scattered they
scattered so you can decentralize what
might be a mob that that's that's coming
is there any discussion in the military
about weapons the effect of weapons on
people that are not just gun that your
traditional well there was not in this
book of one of my previous books there
was infrasound which book this was even
over they were there was this so many
boys you know remember the book that was
in that she wrote that's pretty cool
yeah that's that's badass actually in
some book that I wrote somewhere I
believe I said what you can all you know
there's like buy them all I'm all a
mouse you can point to it that's it you
buy them all right so yeah in but
infrasound there was this talk about
that there that the military was looking
for a non-lethal weapon I think was it
supposedly it would in OCS is infrasound
and it was like long slow way no
frequency wave frequency and that it
would resonant frequency as some of the
internal organs so you it would create
fear nausea terror and yeah never this
is like in Jurassic alright anywhere
t-rex
yeah like the liquid inner right and you
see the the vibration and the liquid in
the glass right right right
that type of deal yeah like they were
sort of like it would launch a ball of
interest but anyway I could never find
be a knob there be t-rex would be one of
the settings right yeah yeah by the way
the military doesn't have to look for
that we already have it it's called one
direction yeah you're a boy band well
there was some concern about NASA had
concerns about because the engines were
put in a launch they would be putting
out tremendous amounts of infrasound and
they were afraid they're going to
deliver jelly to the moon that they
would even it was bad intent but I think
as it turned out it wasn't but in fact
they do have what
call a sound abatement system and before
every launch in the seconds before they
ignite the engine you see this basically
a swimming pools worth of water dumped
Auto Launchpad and the water absorbs the
acoustic reverberations that's right
they're worried that the acoustic
reverberations would just completely
tear apart entire bottom half of the
rocket I like the singer with the glass
breaking shadow exactly yeah except that
so what they do is they put in the water
that absorbs the energy and that way the
energy doesn't hit the rocket again so
next time watch very closely every
single launch and their big tanks
rounding launch pads their water tanks
bada-bing and then the vibrations hit it
vaporizes the water so some of the smoke
you see coming out is is steam basically
it's comprised by the energy the
acoustic energy of vibration that's
amazing give me one more question
by the way that is the exact sound that
it makes when the water is dumped got a
baby if it awesome